the last set of rights we'll discuss in
this lesson are the economic rights of
citizens
these are the rights that citizens have
to control their own property
labor and working conditions
this includes all of the rights
associated with your ability to make
money and your ability to own stuff
the most basic of these rights is to
acquire
use transfer and dispose of property
that is
you can buy stuff you can use it you can
give it or sell it to someone else and
you can throw it away
these property rights also include your
right to receive just compensation for
the taking of private property for
public use which is protected by the
fifth amendment
so if the government decides that they
need your yard because they're building
a highway they must compensate you
fairly for that land
the government also protects your right
to copyright and patent so that you can
sue someone who steals your ideas
work or inventions so this includes your
right to own things that aren't physical
objects or land like a song you wrote
then there are the economic rights that
safeguard your freedom to own your own
labor and the money you earn from it
those include the right to earn a wage
the right to choose your own work and
change your employment and the right to
work in safe conditions
lastly you have economic rights to
associate with and combine your
interests with others
such as the right to join labor unions
and professional associations to
advocate for yourself and for other
members of your profession you can
establish and operate a business and
enter into lawful contracts with others
the ability to own one's own property
labor and business dealings is
foundational to the system of capitalism
in which individuals control economic
organizations rather than the state or
cooperatives
so now let's do a couple of scenarios so
you can check your skills i'll give you
a scenario and you see if you can
identify which economic right is being
exercised or violated number one yale
and a group of her co-workers are
frustrated with the working conditions
at the grocery store they work at
they're forced to work 10-hour days with
only a 30-minute break for lunch several
of her co-workers have started reporting
knee problems because they aren't
allowed to sit yale gathers a majority
of employees to talk about organizing a
union to demand less hours and more
breaks her boss hears about the meeting
and fires yale which right did her
employer violate in this scenario
the right to join a labor union
yale has the right to join unions or
professional associations as she chooses
number two
one day a city council member knocks on
ty's door he tells ty that the city
needs half of his backyard to expand the
public park that sits on the other side
of ty's fence tai refuses to give the
land away but the city council member
tells tai he doesn't have a choice and
that he will receive a check for 50 to
repair the fence once they take it down
tomorrow which right did the city
council violate in this scenario
the right to just compensation for the
taking of private property for public
use
ty's backyard is worth a lot more than
fifty dollars
number three hamza's boss calls him into
his office one day and lets him know
that there's a new opening in another
department in the company but hamza
doesn't want to move departments and
enjoys the job he has
he requests not to change
his boss tells him that if he doesn't
move to the new department she'll have
to fire him instead hamza quits he
starts looking for a new job immediately
which right did hamza use in this
scenario
he used his right to change employment
okay that's all for this video what do
you think is the most important economic
right what would be the consequences if
you didn't have one of these rights